the main thing is always try to give us
much stage time as you can I mean a lot
of times people just want to make it and
they have a couple of jokes in a and
they kill it whenever they go on stage
and they believe like that's all that it
takes but really the more that you
sharpen your knife your machete whatever
it is that you when you're on that stage
and have that ability to walk out there
is something that I you know always
recommend that people just and you know
try to make the money first you know try
to try to be great at what you do first
you know and then even to this day I
mean as you can tell I mean you can hear
from the roar of laughter in the
background I have a tendency you're
putting really sharp comics on in front
of me so that I have to go out there and
put in the work on these guys you know
that's what happens you can get you can
become a pro and get a little lazy and
and have the expectations of Fame but
when people spend their money they want
to laugh and they want to laugh for real
and so I try to put myself in a
situation where you have to go in there
and do the work like it's because guys
these both Henry and JJ these user they
out there throwing rocks at the crowd so
but uh but that's it I mean just stay
encouraged they work and stay and your
mindset yeah and try to stay free of you
know independency trying to like write
things and be true to yourself and look
for the comedy and the humor and the
things that happen to you in life so as
comedians coming up what are what are
some tips you can have as we land this
plane here because this is you know it's
all about just comedy in the comedy game
and what what are some tips you could
maybe share with comics ooh some big
tips all right cut down on the booze
don't go too hard I was uh here's the
problem with booze do you drink not
really good good for you but uh just I
love it so much and I want to party I
want to get drunk but it kills your
whole next day and I have bad anxieties
so when I'm hungover my anxiety goes
through the roof and I'm like you suck
you're gonna bomb this joke isn't good
you're trying to write you're like it
all stinks have you ever written a joke
of your life you kill yourself you suck
you're gay so all that [ __ ] and all that
comes out and I rehab enough of that
sober
so when I'm drinking it's it's even
worse but uh so cut back on the booze
just right right right even you got
nothing in your head just go back to old
tweets look at old jokes try something
on stage if you're doing a new bit and
you're kind of not doing well with it
just throw in three more sentences real
quick like what else always stretch as
much as you can don't go out and bomb a
ton but like what last night I went on
stage I was like I'm gonna riff about
Atlanta a little bit maybe nothing will
come maybe it'll be humiliating but it's
not the end of the world
so even when you're like all right pull
out pull out do three more sentences
just say [ __ ] it it's almost like when
you're doing reps and you're on that
last one and you can't do it but you
want to give up and your friend go it's
just push it a little bit even if you
just get it up to here instead of not
doing it just that will give you some
muscle I think and it's the same with
comedy just push it a little further
just stretch it as much as you can until
you feel them like all right all right
we got it and if you do that enough over
years you'll become amazing because you
you a you're building something B you're
learning what it feels like to be
frazzled and and push that down you know
that feeling of panic when you're on
stage or like this is bombing abort mm
keep going and push your abort button
further away you know so you can build
that that Callos of like I can take a
little bit of bombing I can take it
because I'm such a wuss like people go
oh you got so many punchlines I'm like
yeah I'm scared of silence I'm not this
brilliant writer guy I'm just I'm
punching it up so I don't have to feel
anything so yeah I always push it a
little further try to riff do that joke
that you're scared of doing sometimes
when I'm on stage I'm like a little
nervous out of my element I'm like this
isn't going as well as I hoped that's
when you try the new bit because that's
when you're the most vulnerable and raw
and it'll actually kick you into being
yourself it's almost like when you're
trying to when you're with a girl and
you're trying to be cool and funny and
it's not going that great just go well
this isn't going that great hold on let
me let me reboot here it just it's the
it's the thing your brain is telling you
don't do do that sometimes go towards
that [ __ ] it's like the del closed thing
follow the fear go towards the fear
sometime
your brain saying don't but that's when
you should and it makes the fear go away
ironically go into it lean into the skid
it's like that Bill burr thing he's like
when you're doing stand-up if you're bad
at going to crowd work go to crowd work
cuz you got to learn it and the only way
to learn is to dive in it's like
basketball players I can't go left well
then work on going left same thing so
this is all you know heavy inside
baseball Anil but just you know try try
it's right down though you know you got
that weird Joker like this is weird
try it let's go that what's gonna happen
this is all prey that's the cool about
stand-up it's all batting practice until
TV or the special obviously you don't
want to use the audience too much and
just be like you guys are my canvas I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] on you and whatever
works I'll keep it because then you'll
be a bad comic so play walk that line of
being a pro killing giving them a good
show and working out your [ __ ] and
trying [ __ ] and that's a that's a good
line and I think some people respect it
they want to hear the new [ __ ] they want
to hear you working it out so yeah
that's my tip everything has a process
like with math you learn the formulas
and [ __ ] and then you start to get
results because you can do every [ __ ]
problem if you know the formula you go
homes in you got a formula yeah yeah I
got it for me talk to him
my formula you give up the whole sauce
for real bro without the chef's though
that's what I'm saying you don't let
nobody interrupt your sauce when you
cooking people have lost the
understanding and value of the word you
cuz at the end of the night you gotta
lay down by yourself and get up in the
morning look yourself in the mirror you
gotta be comfortable with all the
decisions that you make as a human and
stop depending on other people to supply
your happiness won't sneeze thoughts and
desires hmm it's selfish but is real
and when you start believing in other
people but that's how you open yourself
up to disappointing this failures
heartbreak depression all that [ __ ]
because your expectations it's the
fastest way to disappointment I'll never
let nobody or nothing disappoint you got
to be comfortable with yourself and know
that you are the key factor that can
change
the old situation your life at the end
of the day you are the [ __ ] you are
the key the other DJ Kelly is a major
key yeah yeah but you are the key and
every time you can put some knowledge
and work it and execute it it's just
like you got another one on your on your
loop of keys the more cheese you got the
less you need from other [ __ ]
if you're looking for somebody to make
you financially happy and that's all you
need you want somebody cuz they got
money or whatever you think they can do
for you think of how you gonna feel when
you in that position and and you're not
looking for nobody else to give you what
you've been craving if money is your
vice and you get some money then what
you're gonna have to find another vice
because money ain't gonna be your it's
not gonna be a drug no more cuz you in
the excess of it and it's the thrill is
gone like though blues song baby came to
thriller is gone it's the thrill of the
chase there's a lot of [ __ ] that we
think that we want until we actually get
it so is that where you are right now
like you've gotten a lot of what you
want and it's not what you thought it
would be no it's not even that it's just
that's why I can say that I'm happy with
where I am in my success as a person no
however people may see it or not I do
what makes me happy you know what I'm
saying sometimes it's not a Ferrari that
[ __ ] that's your dream car your [ __ ]
might be right there in your grass it
might be the [ __ ] Mustang that you
wanted in high school you know I'm
saying you always just wanted to GT or
some crazy [ __ ] what whatever it is that
you desire see that's what separates the
people from Lane like greatness in
regular [ __ ] desire the desire
to be yourself you know I'm saying like
you you look I'm sent here watching
these [ __ ] build his car you
might look at that [ __ ] bill I don't
want that [ __ ] but that's somebody's
dream car that's all they ever wanted
you know I'm saying yeah and so that's
the type of [ __ ] I'm saying they're like
what is it that makes you happy it might
not even be an iPhone it might just you
guys got to live for yourself it's
basically what I'm saying and then what
basically the oh I've attached tacked
anything is just okay who is doing this
the best how do I do it better than them
you have to look at what you want and
then who has it and then how you can
better than them mmm so it's very simple
you know so how can you make this
podcast you're interviewing people okay
who's got the best interview podcast you
know in this field okay
who is he oh he's interviewing more
famous people than me all right I gotta
interview more famous people he's
interviewing more interesting people
than me just analyze who's doing the
thing successfully and then be better
than that who are some people you've
been analyzing in terms of podcasts or
just in your career all you all the
stuff you've been doing I mean you know
first stand-up it was like I just looked
at the game I was like okay what do I
need to do first of all I need to get
undeniably funny that's the first thing
how do I get uh nyah bleah funny again
on stage as much as I can so I was
barking for a club which means handing
out tickets mmm to go to a club exchange
for stage time so I was getting up tons
of times a week in front of a real
audience is very early on in my in my
career I was probably getting up five
seven times a week front of real
audiences early in my career unheard of
so I had to say New York this is in New
York yeah then I stopped working in one
of those clubs I kind of got like fired
from barking or one club close they
didn't ask me to work at the other one
so I I basically we found this other
place that was around the block and they
had shows there and they were just kind
of free shows asking people to come off
the street and I got involved in that
Club and I started working for one of
the guys there and I we were just kind
of friendly and I was running his shows
I just found a place to get up
consistently then I started running a
couple shows there with friends we were
just asked be strangers from the streets
come in and it was great because when
you have your own show you have your own
show a lot of times it might be repeat
audience mm-hmm so you can't work the
same jokes out because it's the same
audience so it's good because you're
practicing new jokes but you're not
getting good in anything you know it's
like you're learning a new like pool
shot every week it's like you're not
getting really better a pool you just
kind of get marginally better at these
new jokes that you never really get to
try hmm but we could work on the same
jokes for months because it was a
different group of people coming in
every week so we did that then I once I
felt like I was undeniably fun
at least funny to the point where I feel
like I could you know be on stage with
these other guys who are on stage and
how long in your career was that a few
years in I mean I mean now I would look
back and be like uh I was awful but for
the time I was able to go you know I'm
good enough to be on the stage with
these guys mm-hmm and I was like why are
they on the stage so I started analyzing
the people I saw at all the clubs and it
was like sure out small like James Smith
and these kind of comics and they were
all best week ever I notice all the
comics who are best week ever we're
performing at all the clubs Christian
Finnegan and I was like okay I need to
get on a show that is a weekly show that
will give me some leverage so net
because not just about funny it's like
if you're as funny as all the other guys
okay you got to be funnier than them and
have something so I got on a guy code
and that was my weekly now I had some
leverage now I can go to a club jam on a
TV show every week can I get on yeah how
do you had you get on guy code I sound
so easy it was kind of there was some
you know one of the good things like
knowing what you want to do do you have
any closing advice or any like of your
favorite comedy wisdom that you've
gathered over being around the top
comics in the world some of it like so
be obsessed is my advice to a lot of
people be obsessed with it okay work as
hard as you can get up as much as you
can you know it's not like you have to
go sit there and write all day long but
just go be out be amongst comics hang
out with comics be around have a fun
time drink party you know it's like
we're in the field that you get a drink
every night like at work that's truly
work like it's it's hanging out and then
you know so be obsessed that comfortable
thing if you start feeling comfortable
that's the best advice you can
everything if you're in wasn't my if you
start feeling comfortable it's time to
make a change if you're in your combi
scene and you're that you can feel
yourself be the higher up of the scene
it's time to make a change maybe you
know whatever whatever you can do
you know and the other advice for this
is probably more older comics I remember
and always told me be comfortable with
silence and so I think this is more like
when I was first starting out it's not
it's not really advice that you know you
don't need to really worry about silence
you need to try to be hearing laughs you
only doing 5-10 minutes but when you
when you start headlining for the first
time it was like I learned like it's
like be comfortable saying is be
comfortable with like some pauses and
like you know sometimes it's good
hearing a big room of 2,000 people you
could hear a pin drop is just as good as
hearing laughter like you know because
you got their attention
yes and so even though it should it be a
long thing like I said you want to be
very close to laughs but even if it's
like 20 seconds and stuff like you know
when you hear that complete silence that
means man these people are engaged and
they're really listening to what you're
saying and that's a and that's a great
great thing how do you create that
engagement I mean you just got a you
feel like you're always on top of them I
feel like I never tried to you know like
I don't ever leave too much like that's
never been too far away from laughs yeah
they kind of you know you just argue
there's in a way there's a panic up
there and the fact that you're I always
know where I'm going I always know where
you're going I always know where you're
going to begin I always know where
you're gonna want to end if you start a
new joke at least have the way to get
into it and a way to get out of it you
don't want to start a joke where you
don't know how to get out of it and you
should have different exits like you
know I have very labs longer jokes where
I can like I can tag it five times and I
can only tag it one time and you know
and you can fill it out maybe if it's a
good crowd I'm gonna tag it all five if
the crowds not you know if it feels like
they're not getting it like other crowds
I'm going to tag at once you just get
out of the job right so like you just
kind of fill the room out it's all a
timing is a very you know timing is big
it's all a very like fluid kind of thing
man like different crowds can make you
do different things you know you have
quick lappers you have long laughters
you have people that clap a lot yeah you
know people that you feel like you got
to stay on top of and you feel like
you're fly
because you're like I'm about to lose
these people you know when you're doing
a Late Show slipper you can film oh yeah
you can film start like looking around
like they're like all right like you
know ya know just say what I mean you're
like you gotta like stay almost like
there's a did all chase yeah there's a
difference between like engage silence
like you said in kind of the apathetic
silence it's a fine line but you said
you can feel them being engaged is it
that personal material that makes them
engage through the silence is that
something one thing I learned with
personal material is I remember I added
an old joke about something about me a
guy met made a mess to message me on
Facebook and I was like message to this
guy and I even know this guy was and
like it was it wasn't even that great of
a joke but when I always noticed it
wouldn't get the biggest laughs but that
was the joke people would always come
and bring up to me after the show and I
was like why are they pointing out this
that's the worst joke of those sets the
other stuff murders it was because
that's personal so they come up to me
because they're like I've done that dude
and so like then that joke means more to
them than the other jokes that don't
mean anything to them like that are just
funny like you can be very forgettable
too like you know you can watch a guy go
onstage and murder like we've been
saying and then no wonder and you go you
when people walk out of a room you'd be
like hey what what jokes did he do you'd
be like I don't know is he because none
of them were personal they were all just
jokes like that anybody could kind of
tell and not to say that they're not
funny and that's not a good thing to do
but if you make them personal and people
are gonna come up to you after the show
and be like dude I done that I did yeah
all right I've done that I've been
through that exact thing I always think
that you want to be either be you just
be the dumb guy and they can either
laugh with you or laugh at you so
they're either gonna laugh with you
because they relate to you or they're
laughing at you because you're an idiot
but both laughs count doesn't really
matter how you laugh so you know that's
how I always kind of do and so yeah
that's it perfect
all right well Nate bargatze thank you
for being on hot breath here buddy
absolutely buddy thank you all right
have a good day hey hot brother and
sister if you love comedy as much as we
do here at
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips